the FBI director and other top US
officials told lawmakers yesterday that
Russian election meddling is not over
intelligence chiefs from six agencies
say the u.s. is already preparing for
Moscow to use propaganda and social
media to quote reduced trust and
confidence in democratic processes
before this year's vote Jeff McGee's is
on Capitol Hill with the strong message
from that hearing
Jeff good morning good morning what the
intelligence Chiefs testified to
yesterday is not what the president has
been saying at intelligence sources
insists that without a unified front
blunting these Russian cyberattacks gets
tougher frankly the United States is
under attack the Director of National
Intelligence warned that Russia is using
cyberattacks to penetrate virtually
every major action that takes place in
the United States the risk of interstate
conflict is higher than any time since
the end of the Cold War according to
this 28 page intelligence community
report Russia views the 2018 midterm
elections as a potential target for
hacking units backed by the Russian
government lawmakers pressed the
intelligence chiefs on whether the
president has taken the threat of
seriously has the president director you
and your agency to take specific actions
to confront and blunt Russian influence
activities that are ongoing we're taking
a lot of specific efforts to blunt
directed by the president not as
specifically directed by the president
last month the White House declined to
impose additional sanctions on Russia
for its meddling in the presidential
election despite near unanimous support
from Congress and the president has been
reluctant to condemn Russian President
Vladimir Putin I believe that he feels
that he and Russia did not meddle in the
election as to whether I believe it or
not I'm with our agencies and with the
president waffling on this issue experts
say these cyber attacks become more
effective just as more countries around
the globe every year get this capability
of carrying out these damaging cyber
attacks also on the increase according
to intelligence
officials is this threat from North
Korea despite its latest charm offensive
at the Olympics Noora interesting Jeff
thank you so much